[Music]
let's go 10 plus Z slightly shorter
video for today let's get the show on
the road okay so we're playing a serious
player 2338 welcome to the people
watching on YouTube it is December 21
almost 3 a.m. so take it easy on
me all right so for some reason this a
lot of people have been aborting on move
one this is not particularly promising
very complex position let's start
analyzing so there's a new move that I
was recently made aware of which is
actually C7 C5 it's an absolutely
revolutionary idea um because all of the
experts say that E5 is the only feasible
move well there we go he's following the
experts okay spotting us 40 seconds
fantastic so we have two options in
response to Knight
C6 we have the GLE system which I've
played quite a bit and we have the R
Lopez a lot of people have been
requesting in the comments section and
through my stream I game in the R Lopez
against a high level opponent which is
what I'm going to do this time we're
going to play the R Lopez and we are
facing a very well-known sideline I
think this is called the bird variation
it's a very old line it's it's been
around for it's been around for a
while and essentially it's what I would
call a third rate sideline but the
benefit of such a move Knight takes D4
is essentially forced is that most R
Lopez players just like don't study
these types of Sidelines carefully or if
they have studied them it's been a long
time since they've reviewed the line and
I am among that number I haven't
reviewed this in many many years I
vaguely remember that Castle's King side
is supposed to be the best move but
that's essentially all that I know
because we're playing a 10-minute game I
don't really have time to delve into the
sort of generalities of this variation
that's what we're going to do after the
game what I remember is that the bishop
is supposed to drop back to C4 rather
than to A4 as his standard in the main
line of the R Lopez Knight F6 and I
vaguely remember the line E5 which is
meant by D5 so we're going to avoid E5
and instead we're going to play D3 play
it solid protect the center and prepare
to develop the bishop D5 all right well
taking seems pretty
normal Knight takes D5 and we should
invest a moment here to try to
understand if we can punish black for
keeping the king in the center this long
the move Rook E1 check should be
essentially everybody's Instinct black
will likely meet it with Bishop E7 and
the second major weakness in Black's
position of course is the D4 Pawn Pawn
which may look imposing but it's
actually a very serious weakness because
if black ever plays C5 to protect that
pawn then the Knight on D5 is going to
become weak so Black's position is very
flimsy but in order to punish it we have
to play accurately here let's think
about this so actually I like the move
Knight to D2 here quite a bit H okay let
me think here here here there's a lot of
promising continuations here
okay we're going to play very
positionally here we're going to go Rook
e one check we're going to play very
very
positionally I didn't find anything
tactical that I liked instead we're
going to opt for what I hope to be a
relatively small but nagging and stable
Advantage which is perfect for this kind
of time control we're going to trade off
the dark squared Bishops we're going to
trade off the dark squared Bishops and
as a result black is left with a very
lame light squ Bishop on E6 and now we
also have the option of taking on D5 and
doubling doubling Black's
pawns
so that seems promising on the other
hand yes Black's pawns are doubled but
the C file opens up and this backward
Pawn on C2 could be pressured by Black's
Rook so it's not entirely obvious that
Bishop takes D5 is best here let's take
another moment I'm investing a lot of
time here but I think it's very
important for to play accurately to
secure our advantage the other option is
to complete our development with Knight
D2 okay let's go for Knight D2 maybe
I'll change my mind after he castles he
castles Queen side okay I honestly
didn't see that at all I didn't even
realize that that was legal now it's an
extremely risky move now it it Dawns on
me that I should have taken on D5
because now black will recapture with
the Rook now we kind of have to opt for
Plan B and pressure this Pawn how are we
going to do that well probably we should
do it from B3 but then Queen G5 is very
scary but Knight F3 he's got Queen
F6 maybe we can jump into E5 there
H yeah I'm sort of feel like I'm
misplaying this all right let's go
Knight B3 let's go Knight B3 very spicy
position C5 okay extremely weakening
move now Queen F3 leaps to mind but
somehow we might not have enough
Firepower to make anything happen if we
and if we can't make anything happen
then Black's position is fundamentally
sound black doesn't actually have any
weaknesses yeah it was a big mistake I
think not to take on D5 when I had a
chance I just missed I just missed long
Castle okay Queen C7 I'm going to have
to speed up a little bit here we could
trade Queens we could send the a pawn
down the
board let's go A4
let's go A4 for starters it's not a very
committal move yeah we're weakening the
B4 square but I'm not too concerned
about that okay Bishop G4 is that a
threat eh it's not really a threat
because we can drop the queen away to G3
let's continue with A5 okay let's throw
in the move A6 probably to weaken his
King side yes let's throw an A6 he's
going to go B6 and then we're going to
go
are we going to go H3 and allow
G5 am I getting crushed here okay let's
go H3 all right no I'm not getting
crushed still feels like white is better
feels like if he moves his Knight he's
going to get
mated okay I guess not Knight F4 that is
a strange
move okay this Knight on B3 is not doing
anything the check on A8 is not
effective as of yet I feel like we
should keep that that in our pocket so
okay let's go Knight D2 let's go Knight
D2 trying to reroute the Knight toward
the center and keeping the tension I I
want to trade on on our terms if he
takes on C4 that's amazing because that
helps our Knight get to an excellent
Square okay now it feels like we're
taking over the initiative but I don't
have a lot of
time so maybe now we should take but
then he takes with the pawn H okay let's
take just for the sake of
Simplicity takes with the pawn okay all
right now is it time for us to well
first of all it's time to move let's get
our Knight into the
action I like this move more than Knight
E4 because it keeps the diagonal open
for the queen and it sets up the
potential for maybe Knight takes B6 if
the black queen moves away also of
course the main idea okay I expected
this wait a minute Knight takes B6 Queen
takes B6 and Rook A3 is a pretty
incredible idea but it doesn't quite
work because he has King C7 Rook B3 and
D TS he gets away okay okay speed up
speed up there is Knight E5 and there is
Rook
A3 Rook A3 now very important detail if
he plays Rook to D5 trying to block the
diagonal we have Rook takes E6 removing
the guard
obviously okay he goes back to C now
this has to be losing he's playing for
the clock here it's very very clear to
me okay here we let's not rush let's
let's
think there there there there's just so
much to calculate here I don't
understand how he's playing so quickly
amazingly I just don't see the force to
win here just
yet okay here God I'm I on every move I
keep trying to find the force win and I
keep not finding it and as a result I'm
burning like a ton of clock I might lose
this game on time because now again
check King D7 Knight E5 Queen E5 and
he's winning God how is this this is
crazy okay Queen up ah that was a bad
move he wasn't actually threatening
anything I should have gone Rook A1 that
was really stupid okay Rook A1 now it's
going to get spicy because I'm
threatening Knight takes B6 finally I
have a threat finally I have a threat
okay he defends with King D7 but now now
what is this this is just crazy play by
our opponent check picking up rook e one
getting the Rook back into the action I
want to go C3 Rook F5 okay now check he
has to go back to
D7 okay I think we should go C3 here God
this is going to be so interesting to
analyze that's the positive of this game
but this is so nerve-wracking because
also it's so easy to miss a tactic here
for white okay ghost takes should I go
D4
no we should take with the Rook get the
Rook into the attack much more important
than Pawn structure God he's he's just
trying to flag me okay let's go D4 open
up the
center he can't move the Knight that's
that's huge if he moves the Knight he
walks into Knight C4 wa now now he's
dead lost okay now we take open up the
defile okay he has to take and then B4
is probably
winning can I go for sacrifice here
Knight C4 King
D7 God it's it's crazy how hard it is to
find the force win here on B4 I think is
winning Rook D1 Knight D5 and he's
surviving okay let's go B4 let's go
B4 this guy has like 8,000 lives Rook B5
Rook D1 Knight D5 still surviving what
the heck I don't get this he's he's
actually going to win if I don't
Knight D5 yeah no but I take a knight
C4 did I get it I got it I think Knight
C4 yes we got him check holy smokes and
I take on E6 but it's still not over he
has King B5 but Knight D6 yes bang we
win oh my
gosh mom
spaghetti yeah okay but now with 30
seconds I'll I'll win this pretty easily
I think plenty of time I just need like
one or two accurate moves here we're
going to go after the A7 pawn and
combine it with an attack against the
king Rook B1 obviously still need to be
fast and accurate here okay the goal is
to play Rook B7 he's probably going to
go
E5 you're always allowed to give Subs
okay up to B7 we
go if possible we're going to trade the
Rooks but the priority is to go after
this
Pawn Yeah Queen A7 he's he might give us
a check just watch out for the Knight
getting to F1 because that is a
Perpetual mechanism um King C6 okay back
to B1 and that's it too many
threats what a game what a crazy
game kudos to our opponent for like
defending like an absolute Beast I
really really did my best to play
accurately I didn't just want to throw
pieces at him and as a result it it
almost cost me the game on the
clock okay here we can give a
check and push A7 no the ROP his can be
very
tactical the clinical way to win this
okay this is just mate the clinical way
to win this is to get rid of his Knight
ASAP if you get rid of his Knight then
you can pre everything and win okay I
actually don't have pre enabled but it I
have enough time now we just bang it out
we take H4 we promote a second Queen and
we ladder Checkmate him actually the
fact that I don't have pre moves enabled
is a slight problem if I had like 5
Seconds yeah he's like trying to ice the
kicker like waiting 5 10 seconds to make
a move hoping that I like take my foot
off the gas pedal but it's not going to
work I have way way way enough time I
can actually just chill okay sorry
YouTube people this is slightly boring
but hey it's part of the
experience I'm just going to close my
eyes no I'm not I'm going to close my
eyes and move when I hear the
sound okay it's a little bit scary no I
would I I don't want to enable pre moves
cuz I'll get
stuck okay there we
go man mate
cool GG okay 63 moves but in reality the
the bulk of the game lasted 37
moves yeah what a game okay let me load
this into chess base because we are
definitely going to need the engine to
decipher how many and I'm sure that
there were a million mistakes in the
Tactical portion of the game okay let me
see if I have any books on on the R
Lopez yes I do have
books yes perfect so if there are any
people like over 2,000 watching this and
you want a very high level book on the R
Lopez it's uh Dar the Polish GM who
lives in in St Louis a heroa two volume
series uh pretty recently 2021 that is
excellent and a lot of people ask like
oh how do you use opening books like are
opening books good at my level opening
books are mostly like a reference right
right it it's like a dictionary like do
you read a dictionary no presumably um
unless you're participating the spelling
be what do you use a dictionary for well
you you use it to look up a word and
that's exactly the way that I would use
a opening book that I consider to be
reliable like somebody played a line
against me I either don't know the line
or I want to refresh uh the right course
of action rather than analyzing on my
own in chess Bas using a book is just an
easy way to have the information
spoonfed to you
um same with the chess of course but I
like the old school way of finding it in
a book there's a certain charm to it
that I think makes it fun so let's see
what darish has to say on the board this
is a pretty big section his section on
the bird's defense just so you know is
11 pages the font's pretty big but
that's just how thorough he is so a
little history if we look at uh
reference this move was first played
1848 oh 1856 by Howard Stanton Howard
Stanton actually played this twice in
1856 and
1858 uh bird himself played it many many
times uh in the 1860s and 70s that's
where it got the name and uh a lot of
the early good players choran has some
games here Rudolph Spielman nimich oh
alakin yeah back in the old days this is
a really popular move and this is a very
like independent line it doesn't
resemble anything at all this structure
is reached exactly in no other line in
the real Lopez so in a sense this game
is like a false R Lopez this line stands
on its own and there's a couple of lines
in the R Lopez that stand on their own
another one of course is the uh schan or
the yanish with
F5 most of the other lines lead to sort
of the typical maybe the Berlin endgame
I think the Berlin endgame also falls
into that category of yeah it's a Lopez
but this is like a standalone you know a
standalone variation it's like a country
within a a
country
um but most of the other lines like
whether you go main line with A6 or D6
you get this sort of typical R Lopez
structure but still Knight D4 is a very
important move to know now if you're an
Italian player you might be aware of a
very famous opening trap uh the
Blackburn Shilling gam at Knight D4 is
possible against Bishop C4 it's a very
bad move if white simply takes the
Knight you essentially get a R Lopez
bird up a Tempo uh but the unsuspecting
player will take on E5 who knows the
entirety of this famous opening trap who
wants to spell it out in the chat if
you're watching on YouTube you can
demonstrate your knowledge by banging
this out on the board next to you
correct Queen to
G5 white gobbles up F7 with a fork white
gets excited I've seen this all play out
in a lot of kids games Queen takes G2 so
you say no problem let me just move the
Rook to F1 and now I'm going to calmly
take your rook in the corner nope check
and does black win the queen no it's
mate on F3 a lot of online games have
gone like this but in any case if you're
an Italian player do not take on E5 just
Castle or take on D4 all right so Bishop
E5 Knight C4 now let's get to the uh now
let's get down to business here's what
darer says Birds defense is considered
as a slightly suspicious line but it is
nonetheless essential to know how to
react with white in order to get an
advantage in 2013 I played a game
against report who is a specialist in
this line and I did not react well and
quickly got myself into trouble and this
is the misconception about these quote
unquote bad lines right they're actually
not that terrible if you don't react
accurately to them which is why even GMS
sometimes surprise other GMS with an
objectively dubious line in the hopes
that they haven't reviewed it in a while
so darish gives takes takes and castles
and here black has a couple of options
um the most popular move is Bishop C5
closely followed by C6 these are
essentially the only two legitimate
moves against Bishop C5 darish gives the
immediate Bishop C4 and uh this sets the
obvious tactical trap Bishop F7 and
queen H5 and here's a quick overview of
some variations that darish gives this
is like a a very very thorough
analysis okay
so D6 is by far the most obvious move he
also gives Queen H4 which is not scary
because after D3 Knight E7 this queen
can be chased away Knight D2 castles and
Bishop drops back to B3 Bishop drops
back to B3 the point is so that D5 uh
does not come with Tempo and then you're
going to go F4 and Knight F3 chasing
away the queen with a great position
okay so Queen H4 is not scary
everybody's going to go Knight F6 then
you can already go E5 and black is
totally busted because if black tries to
play D5 in this position this is
obviously like a much inferior version
because after it takes takes we can
simply take on G7 and then throw the
queen up to H5 and we win the game on
the spot so that's terrible black has to
go D6 first now we play D3 and here the
main line is C6 so as I understand it
the basic idea is that this Knight is
going to develop to D2 and we're going
to play on the king side in one of
several ways I'm also noticing that
darish really likes the idea of dropping
the bishop back to B3 proactively uh so
that black doesn't have like these
various Tempo moves like B5 uh and and
D5 if black plays Knight F6 we have
Bishop G5 with a really nice pin if
black plays Queen E7 then we start
running the F Pawn up the board and uh
we just run the pawn up to F5 and close
off the bishop the moment the Knight
moves away we start assembling pieces on
the king side with a huge attack Queen
f8 now simply Knight D2 wow King E King
D7 Bishop B6 check black is getting
crushed mvl against David how
2009 very nice okay so after black plays
C6 we drop the bishop back to B3 Knight
F6 and H3
white stops Bishop G4 and Knight G4 and
keeps all options in hand in my opinion
white is slightly better darish gives A5
A4 obviously castles now the bishop
comes out Bishop E6 and Knight D2 plus
equals I believe white is at least
slightly better here the pin is very
annoying potential for a kingside attack
exists with F4 and it's unclear what
black is doing
here clear enough okay now I skipped
over a lot of Sidelines and VAR a but
this is the overview against Bishop C5
so Bishop C5 you drop the bishop back to
C4 you push D3 Bishop B3 and H3 are good
prophylactic moves the dark squ Bishop
goes out to G5 and the Knight should be
developed to D2 and we keep in mind the
idea of pushing F4 okay now we get to
the the fun part our opponent's move was
C6 okay Bishop C4 I assume is correct
and Knight F6 is indeed the main line um
dark also gives D5 but this looks like a
terrible move takes takes and Bishop B5
check with a great position that's just
not not serious so Knight F6 is the only
serious option D3 exclamation mark okay
so I managed to follow darosa's
recommendation after careful analysis I
came to the conclusion that this is the
simplest path to an advantage okay so
main line for black here is indeed D5
we're literally following the main line
from Dar is's books if black plays the
commer approach D6 then we already kind
of know how to play this position right
we start with Knight D2 then he gives
H3 white prepares Knight F3 and white is
better castles Knight F3 C5 and Rook E1
white has several plans available we can
push C3 we can push E5 White's position
is very very pleasant here okay so this
is also not particularly dangerous the
principled move is D5 takes takes rookie
one check still following uh still
following dar's recommendation Bishop
E7 if black plays Bishop E6 we drop the
queen into H5 threatening Rook takes C6
Queen D7 Bishop takes D5 and Daria says
that this end game is really good for
white because the weak D4 Pawn is very
likely to fall how should white meet
Rook C8 quick exercise to make sure that
people have not fallen asleep yet what
should white do in this
position it looks like black has beaten
us to the punch but no yeah Knight B3 or
Knight F3 Rook takes C2 Knight takes D4
and we win a pawn The Rook has to drop
back we take the Knight we take the
bishop we take the pawn The Rook comes
back to E2 stopping Rook C2 and we are
simply a healthy Pawn up in the end game
very concrete line very important to
know so after Bishop E7
darish gives Bishop G5 I'm actually
pretty pumped I managed to find like all
of the moves up to this point so my my
long thinks did not go in vain and now
let me explain a little bit how I was
able to how I approached this position
so far all of my moves have been
incredibly natural but Bishop G5 might
not be the mo like the first thought
that people have the point of this move
is is not to try to win the game quickly
right this is the misconception that a
lot of people would have you might look
at this move and say oh I'm trying to
like go after E7 actually this is a very
positional move my point was that if
black castles which is actually uh
darius's main move I wanted to trade on
E7 and play Knight D2 and my thought was
that our Bishop is much much better than
its counterpart the center is wide open
and we have the E file and white is just
like positionally better darish gives
Knight G6 Queen H5 plus minus white has
control over the E file more Ive pieces
pressure against the D4 Pawn many many
plans white is much much
better so that was simply the
idea right so our opponent plays Bishop
E6 and this move is not given by darish
uh this is the first move that darish
does not consider there are seven games
in the database so we're still following
some games Bishop takes E7 Queen takes
E7 and this is a critical moment and
here I made a relatively serious error I
think and I'm checking the engine Knight
D2 still maintains a clear Advantage but
a nearly decisive Advantage could have
been reached with Bishop D5 cd5 and
Knight D2 and and somehow I guess I just
didn't appreciate how good this position
is but but once I look at it on the
board it it becomes very very clear why
black is in so much trouble so I was
worried about the pressure on C2 but
Rook C8 doesn't even create a threat
once the D4 Pawn Falls our Knight is
going to be an absolute monster on that
square and the bishop is going to be
lame for the rest of the game so this is
just a nearly decisive positional
Advantage black is likely to Castle
we're going to go Knight
B3 okay obviously black has to try to
defend the pawn and here there's a very
very nice plan look at what the engine
gives Queen to
E2 what is the idea of this move who can
tell me there's actually two ideas but
the one I want you to name is the
straightforward one the idea is to play
Queen E5 very good and win the D4 Pawn
so Black's response is forced Rook a to
C8 now we start by playing Rook a to C1
reinforcing the threat of Queen E5
there's one game in the database where
black goes Rook to C6 and now Queen to
E5 is good but black has this very
tricky idea to get the Rook to B6 and
tie the Knight down so an even better
approach according to the computer is
toen kto the queen on F2 F3 for example
Rook F C8 and you literally pre move
Queen F2 and finally black plays Rook B6
and who can tell me the final piece of
the puzzle no actually there's two more
pieces of the puzzle look at the battle
the epic battle around the D4 Pawn black
is trying everything to keep that pawn
protected okay why can't we play Knight
D4 because the B2 Pawn Falls don't be
afraid to play the straightforward move
right this is the basic idea don't be
afraid to play a quote unquote dumb
straightforward move if it solves the
main problem that you're facing
no but C3 eradicates Black's weakness
you don't want to go C3 because not only
does it blunder a pawn it it gets rid of
the pawn that you're trying to win Rook
B1 simply Rook B1 if black goes back to
C6 then we already pick up D4 Black's
only way to defend the pawn is Rook
B4 we get the Rook to a terrible square
and the final piece of the puzzle is
this move F4 mission accomplished Rook
E5 is Unstoppable and this move works
just the same way that Queen E5 did the
D4 Pawn will fall and black is just
losing like H6 for example Rook E5
that's it Knight takes D4 is coming so
pretty incredible this is move 22 this
line I would argue is almost forced
because what else is black going to do
right black has to Castle black has to
defend the pawn queen F6 is the most
logical way uh to do that I guess Queen
H4 is also possible yeah here we can go
like Queen D2 and then stick the The
Rook on E5 this queen is just going to
be super
misplaced um Queen B4 we can just chase
the queen away yeah Queen E2 Rook C1
look at how we're combining prophylactic
moves and and active moves right Rook C1
is prophylactic F3 furthers our plan
prophylactic and now A3 prophylactic
getting the Rook to a bad score and F4
followed by Rook E5 so really really
interesting how I didn't cash my chips
in when I should I figured let's leave
the options open and if black had
castled then probably I would have
reverted back to the correct course but
major kudos to our opponent for uh for
for for castling Queen side which is the
correct move all right so now I play
Knight B3 and the reason I put the
Knight on B3 is because uh should the
queen move away from E7 in response to
Queen F6 I was intending to circle the
Knight around to C5 and put pressure on
the bishop and the the pawn our opponent
plays C5 which I think is a good move
okay Queen F3 is very natural uh
threatening Bishop takes D5 getting the
queen into the game our opponent is
playing very accurately here and A4 also
I would argue a relatively
straightforward move uh the idea of this
move was born out in the game I'm just
trying to shove the pawn up to
A6 um according to the computer the
position is now equal but it's certainly
doesn't feel equal H5 is correct our
opponent initiates his own operation on
the king side okay
A5 and my secondary idea was that if
black freezes the pawn with A6 um we
revert to a positional course of action
who can tell me the perhaps very
unexpected move here because you might
be in attack mode but one of the things
that you have to be able to do in
complex positions is very quickly switch
between like straightforward attack
attacking play versus suddenly switching
to something more positional not Knight
D2 so what you should notice is what has
been the effect of this change in Pawn
structure it's the fact that the C5 Pawn
can no longer be defended by the move B6
so it's a simple task of removing the
defender Queen to G3 removing the
defender by offering a queen trade and
suddenly black is in trouble because if
black takes it earlier this would not
have been a problem black would have
just gone B6 now B6 obviously we just
play ab and we win okay now you might
say well black doesn't have to cooperate
black can play Queen to C6 but now we
have kind of the higher ground we can
play H4 to freeze Black's pawn and our
Rook can come in E5 it should be pretty
clear to you that like Black's pieces
are now super super
awkward okay uh so that was the idea our
opponent plays H4 which is also a pretty
good move and same thing against Bishop
G4 I intended to play Queen G3 one sec
Let me
refresh okay so I intended to play Queen
G3 H4 we throw in the move A6 and after
B6 I figured that we need to play H3 I
didn't want to allow black to play H3
and create long-term weaknesses on the
king side and I think this is actually a
a critical moment this is where our
opponent made a grave grave error Knight
F4 was a really really bad move really
really bad move why is Knight F4 a bad
move well I think the reason is pretty
simple it opens up these incredible
Prospect for our Queen and it doesn't
actually do anything the trade of
Bishops favors white because we are
controlling the E file and once the E
file opens up we get another front that
we can attack on I think our opponent
kind of panicked here the correct move
according to the engine was Rook to H6
Rook to H6 and the position is very
double-edged But ultimately equal what
is the idea simple you're getting the
Rook to F6 chasing away the queen from
its optimal post and according to the
computer one way that the game can end
is actually repetition of moves um can
white go for the win with Queen E2 yes
but here black can tuck the king away on
B8 and white is running out of active
ideas if you triple suddenly black drops
into F4 and now it's black who's
developing this very very strong attack
against G2 Rook H6 was an excellent move
a hard move to find you can also go King
B8 and essentially just keep the tension
and at this very high level in so far as
people do have a weakness at at the
level of like 22 2300 standard rating it
often is like the inability to keep the
tension they feel like they have to you
know do something for something rather
than playing a slow methodical move like
King B8 and after Knight F4 the real fun
begins the top computer move is
absolutely insane I have zero Shame
about missing it and it actually wins
the game the eval is plus three it's a
beautiful move this move was on my radar
for the record but I didn't appreciate
it its strength vacon pendo got it no
someone is proposing Rook takes C6 but
that why what does that do yes you got
it uh Rook to E5 Rook to e freaking five
right immediately highlighting the I was
going to say the Badness like the the
error of Knight F4 because now clearly
The Rook is Untouchable but the point is
to slice off the connection between the
Knight and the queen so first of all the
Knight is hanging and I actually forgot
about this so the Knight is hanging what
happens if the Knight moves well if the
Knight moves then we're able to take the
bishop and ruin Black's Pawn structure
and we just take on E6 and Black's
position crumbles immediately okay
that's pretty obvious what else can
black do in this position well black can
play Bishop takes C4 first here we
simply recapture on C4 and now black can
move the Knight away and it may appear
the black is okay but that's an illusion
let's say black plays Knight E6 now
white just plays positionally the basic
idea if you just look at this position
without calculating any moves what is
Black's next move what is black about to
do nothing there is nothing that black
can do because of the power of the Pawn
on A6 and because of our domination over
this long diagonal right this is the
power of static Advantage black can't
move the Queen the King has nowhere to
go black can't really control either of
these two squares and The Rook dominates
the Knight so we simply build up our
initiative and so if you consider this
framework the next few moves should make
sense Rook A1 get the Rook into the game
King B8 now which piece is not playing
to its full potential well clearly these
three pieces are well how about the
Knight you might say oh let's go Knight
D2 but but no we won't be able to go
Knight E4 because the Rook will hang
Knight to
C1 Knight to C1 you're getting the
Knight to D3 and you might say well okay
well what happens after all of that is
is done so let's just make a couple of
random moves for black Rook G8 Knight D3
let's say black just plays like Rook f8
finally it's time to convert our
domination into concrete action pause
the video if you're watching on YouTube
the final part of the invasion is also
very instructive it often happens that
once all the pieces are optimized it's
time to use the pawns to break apart and
actually create invadable points in the
opponent opponent's position yeah B4 B4
we're threatening to take on C5 so black
has to take the Knight takes on B4
threatening the fork on C6 black has to
defend and now look at this C5 again
we're trying to open the B file if BC
then we just go Rook B1 with decisive
threats if black plays Knight takes C5
then well the seventh rank has been open
Rook E7 Knight D7 and Knight to D5 look
at this I mean just total complete and
utter domination and some beautiful
lines if Queen to
D6 Knight to F6 threatening made on B7
Knight to C5 black has to defend Rook B7
check and the game ends if black plays
Rook C7 here then it's a lot less
glorious you just play Rook E8 check and
check made on B7
if black plays Queen to C6 here then the
line is also not very glorious you can
just win with Rook takes D7 and bring
the other Rook to E7 you can also do
this against Queen to D6 by the way
Queen to C6 and now
wow incredible idea Queen F4 check King
A8 and now an amazing move a beautiful
move even though it doesn't sacrifice
anything who can spot the idea
incredible move very instructive no no
no don't just randomly sack Knight B6 AB
that's nothing I think a lot of you
watching on YouTube really want to go
Knight C7 check right now but Knight C7
is less convincing black can actually
take and the game goes
on so the idea here is that what's the
mating Square well the mating square is
B7 well how do we get to B7 well one way
to get to B7 would be to open up somehow
the long diagonal if we can get the
queen away from the long diagonal Queen
can jump to F3 so the correct move is a
retreating knight move Knight to B4 and
the intention is simple the queen has no
squares along this diagonal every square
is covered literally no matter where the
queen moves we will either have F3 or E4
with check made on
B7 if black plays G5 you can actually
still take the queen and deliver Arabian
mate how about that line let's go
through that one more
time okay the correct move is Rook E5
tactic six and once black takes and goes
knight6 there's the buildup phase where
we bring our rook in or bring our Knight
in then the opening up the opposing s's
King phase B4 and then the decisive
Invasion using sacrifices to open up new
Pathways particularly for our heavy
pieces C5 Knight C5 Rook E7 getting the
knight in and here we can also play Rook
takes D7 or Knight
F6 and then the final tactical stage
leading to Checkmate okay that was a
long analysis this is going to be a long
video but I really really think this
game is super instructive and I hope you
enjoyed that uh that
analysis okay so in the game I played
Knight tod2 and hopefully you don't
blame me for this I had the right
General concept of making relatively
slow improving I just didn't see Rook E5
okay so G5 by our opponent he sticks to
his guns by the way if we play Rook to
E5 in this position it's not as good
because black and dropped the bishop
back to D7 and now the Knight is no
longer hanging so that ship has sailed I
played Bishop takes C6 check uh F takes
C6 and now once again Rook E5 is best
but Knight C4 is also quite good
completing the maneuver our opponent
should have played Rook H to f8 and try
to create counterplay against the Queen
instead he went King B8 but obviously
this does not help the cause because
Queen B7 is still mate now Rook A3
computer does not love this move what
was the idea well the idea is to set up
the thread of Knight takes B6 I
considered this move immediately and
this is what was taking me so long I was
like looking at all these tactical moves
and they never seem to work cuz like AB
A7 is just winning after Queen B6 Rook
A3 it looks really good but black can
just make a run for it King C7 Rook B3
Queen takes A6 and the attack Fizzles
out we no longer have the B7
Square okay so that's why I decided set
it to prepare with Rook A3 again
according to the engine the correct
approach was just to double on the E
file like this is always what the
computer likes doing playing like super
super slowly and then like getting the
Knight around to B5 but I wanted to mate
him immediately Rook A3 not a bad move
actually and uh King C8 I think is a
very decent defense now Rook B3
reinforcing the potential idea of Knight
takes B6 check okay so I'm not giving
you all the engine moves like here
according to the engine Rook hf8
maintained good defensive chances but
that's not the point of this analysis he
plays Rook df8 Queen E4 Queen E4 again
according to the engine is a mistake uh
the correct approach would have been to
give a check first on A8 and then come
back to E4 and the reason is not what
you might think the reason you give this
check is actually very very deep now
let's for a moment take the defensive
side here so far our opponent has been
defending very well now when you're
defending for a long time it's very very
important not to miss the opportunity
when you can launch a Counterattack
often times when the opposing side the
attacking side keeps attacking keeps
attacking it's very very easy to forget
that your own King may eventually end up
being vulnerable and I think our
opponent lost this game because he
missed ultimately missed the opportunity
to create counterplay against our King
and this was the moment to do it the
correct move was G4 yeah G4 H takes G4
and suddenly after h 3 it turns out that
White's King is under serious fire I
thought that I could play G3 but now
suddenly H2 check and Knight H3 and F2
is hanging and believe it or not this is
a draw it's a crazy draw Queen takes E6
King B8 Knight takes B6 White's got some
tricks in the bag too Knight takes F2
check King G2 now not promote because
white just takes it you take the Knight
Rook takes B6 King A7
not King A8 because of Queen to D5 check
and then check on B7 check on B7 Queen
takes Pawn takes things are starting to
fizzle out H1 Queen takes takes black
has a thousand pieces for the queen and
so white has to force Perpetual
check like this and then just like the
checks along the six rank because black
is also threatening the devastating Rook
F2 very simple line yeah very how did we
both not spot this
instantly but what's
what's the subtlety why should we have
forced the king to D7 and yes the king
is more vulnerable here but what
specifically is the idea of to check on
A8 who can tell me okay now I'm I'm kind
of spoon feeding you this yeah very good
knight5 check stops the counterplay and
you can just pick up the pawn on G4 and
that Knight keeps the king completely
safe yeah again how did I not see that
our opponent misses the chance he he
tries to make one more Preparatory move
and that gives me the chance now to
strike first now I set up the threat of
Knight takes B6 and G4 comes a little
bit too late because I'm able to play
Knight takes B6 he has to take A7 and
very importantly we have enough eyes on
the A8 square if King D7 were able to
promote and we just emerge with an extra
exchange black is just not just not fast
enough if if he takes we make a second
Queen and that's obviously
Checkmate no G takes H3 where but he
doesn't have time for G takes H3 if he
plays it here we can give this check
black is just not in time any questions
about this so our opponent was alert he
makes a run for it to D7 apparently King
to d8 was better now Knight E5 check
centralizing the Knight and now I'm
really proud of the move Rook E1 just
getting the Rook back to the center
solidifying everything and just keeping
the tension and now I found the correct
move C3 all of the pieces have been
optimized just like in that line where
the Knight got to D3 when all of your
pieces are optimally placed it's often a
sign that you need to change the pawn
structure you need to introduce a new
element of pressure and often that means
using the pawns to kind of carve out new
avenues for your pieces that's what led
me to C3 it's really the only feasible
breakthrough and Black's position
crumbles immediately DC Rook takes C3
right the point here is not to maintain
your Pawn is to get your pieces into the
game this sets up more threats of of
breakthroughs and now the final stage
Rook to B8 okay B4 is good I'm just
checking with the engine if I played
decently D4 is correct Queen C8 DC is
correct B4 is the second best move
Knight C4 check also winning Rook B5 BC
Rook
C5 and uh yeah I actually played
correctly Queen D4 takes a knight C4
one other thing if black had gone King
E7 there was a very important detail I
spotted this detail how does white win
in the most efficient way how does white
win in the most efficient way here okay
very good all right very good Knight two
C6 check King F6 and simply Knight takes
A7 another concept that I've highlighted
a lot which is that you want to avoid
getting into Checkmate mode where all
you're looking for is some sort of
sacrifice or mate remember that we
haven't actually sacked anything we can
just take all of Black's pieces that is
a completely viable way of winning the
game Queen A6 just take on B5 just push
the dam pawn and make another queen all
right so so don't stop looking for ways
to win material just because your
primary goal is to attack the king Rook
takes C5 Queen D4 check now if Rook to
D5 uh then we can win in a variety of
ways but the absolute simplest is
probably okay Queen B4 check is winning
um they can yeah Queen B4 check Rook to
C5 Rook to D1 check Knight to D5 it's
crazy how resiliently he defended now we
take on C5 wow Knight C4 check beautiful
King C6 Knight A5 check and the Knight
circles around to B7 with the
fork that's the most efficient win
Knight C4 Knight A5 Knight B7 actually
wait no Queen B7 is made Queen B7 is
made in one but this is a beautiful idea
nonetheless and finally finally we take
on C5 another retreating knight move and
here the final detail is that I have
this move Knight D6 check which which
ends the game then we can oh actually
the king can't even get to the fourth
rank black loses all of his pieces and
that's that okay he gave up the queen
but the rest the rest is clear without
further
commentary that's the game ladies and
gentlemen
yeah this is why the R Lopez is so much
fun because you get games like this it's
it's a very rich opening Knight D4 is a
very rich line actually a little bit
underrated it's it's easy for white to
to laugh at this move but as you can see
there's a lot of meat on the
bone so to conclude I did manage to find
All the Right Moves at the start but the
key was to cash in to go for the
positional Advantage when you got a
chance of course I missed long castle
that started the fun
and then one of the main takeaways one
of the main themes of this game is that
even when you're attacking you have to
be able to kind of slow down you have to
have various gears and you can't beat a
good player with just one gear like you
can't be in go mode the entire time and
you have to be able to pause and say
wait a second now it's time to slowly
accumulate the attack by improving my
pieces and we saw that at several points
in this game of course Rook E5 is
brilliant we we saw this here with Rook
a to E1
and then Knight C1 to D3 and we saw this
also in the game where I was ultimately
able to win because I just sort of okay
I made a lot of mistakes but ultimately
I was just able to bring my Rook to E1
prepare the attack and then open up the
center with
C3 okay I could probably talk about this
game for another hour but the time has
come for us to end I'm exhausted this
has turned out into a long video I
wasn't really planning for that but I
got really really into the game uh so
this will be up on YouTube pretty soon
thanks everybody happy holidays hope you
get to spend some time with your family
on your loved ones thank you for all of
the support everybody this was a really
fun stream and I will see you guys later
have a good
[Music]
one